It's time now to look how we get our clients into a server and then travel from that server to another server.
In Unreal, there are two ways to travel, that being the seamless and non-seamless methods.
What these mean is more meaningful when regarding them from the client's perspective.
Seamless travel means there will be no blocking operations when traveling to a new server.
However, on the other hand, non-seamless travel will cause a blocking call.
In terms of a client, the client is forced to disconnect from the server
and once all of that is done, it will reconnect back to the same server which will now have a new map to load into.
There are three scenarios in which non-seamless travel must occur.
Firstly, when loading a map for the first time.
Secondly, when connecting to a new server for the first time.
And thirdly, when we end a multiplayer game and start a new one.
There are three main functions that drive traveling in Unreal, so let's take a look at these.
The first function is the browse function within the UEngine.
It's essentially a hard reset when loading a new map and will always result in a non-seamless travel.
It's going to cause the server to disconnect the current clients before traveling to the new map.
And it's worth noting that a dedicated server cannot travel to another server.
In other words, we can't browse to another URL, we must browse to a local map.
Then we have the server travel which is held in the UWorld
and the client travel which is held inside the player controller.
The server travel is of course server only and will cause the server to jump to a new level.
Bringing all connected clients with it.
The server is in charge of calling this function so we can't call it from a client.
And it will call the client travel function on all its connected clients for us.
Following that we have client travel and if called from a client we will be traveling to a new server.
If called from the server it will instruct the client to travel to the new map with them.
And importantly it will maintain the connection to the server.
The client won't get disconnected and then reconnected, they will maintain their connection.
Actors can be recognized as persistent and will travel from the previous level to the new.
This is extremely useful for certain actors that you may want to persist through your server move.
By default these actors persist through the level, we have the game mode.
As well as any actors picked up from the Get Seamless Travel actor list inside the game mode.
As well as that we have all controllers that have valid player states on the server only.
Also on the server we will get any player controllers.
In addition we will also get all local player controllers on both the server and the client.
As well as any actors picked up from there Get Seamless Travel actor list too.